Hey guys I'm Erik Voss and now I'm away from the studio on vacation so I'm coming to you voice only this time
Which means you don't have to look at my dumb face, but you are still stuck with my voice
It'd be great if I could, like, spice it up, with a charming, Australian accent, or something
(With horrible accent)
Vegemite
(In normal voice)
Uh, nope, that's not going to work. Anyway, a lot of you have been asking about Rogue One a Star Wars Story
And I want to make a quick video to answer one big question: Why are there so many shots in the trailers and promo footage that didn't make it into the final film
And quick spoiler warning here before I go any further
Ok, so there are at least 46 deleted shots from the trailers that didn't make it into the final film
Many of which we dissected like crazy in our past trailer breakdown videos on this channel
And most of these showed an extended sequence on Scarif, with Jyn evading a tie fighter, stormtroopers, and AT-ACTs, or @-ACTs if you're a psycho
On a beach while holding the stolen Death Star plans, instead of just transmitting them through the antenna, like she did in the final version of the movie
And joining Cassian in one final embrace on the beach
So, many of you are wondering if there was an alternate ending to Rogue One, and if so, what that alternate ending was
Now before I get to my theory, I should remind you all that, last June, weeks after that very first teaser,  with all those now deleted shots
came out, rumors spread about reshoots taking place
Some sources said up to 40% of the film was being reshot, including the film's ending, and that the script's writer, Tony Gilroy, was stepping in to help direct them
But, Disney and LucasFilm downplayed these rumors saying it was just a few tweaks of people talking in cockpits
And that every major action film these days has reshoots
And that's true
And, sometimes movies will put alternate shots in trailers that they never used in the final movie
-Go get 'em boss
-You complete me
-But then, more recently after Rogue One came out, Gareth Edwards, the director, said that a very early draft of the script did have an alternate ending
in which, a few of the main characters actually survive
Because, Edwards assumed that Disney wouldn't want such a dark, Star Wars movie
But then apparently, Kathleen Kennedy was cool with everyone dying, so that's the version of the story that was eventually shot
But, that doesn't really explain why they shot all this extra footage, and then decided to remove it
Clearly, there was another version of this ending that they did change during reshoots
So here is my best guess of what that was, based on deleted shots, plus the most exciting version of this movie I can think of, based on my love of Star Wars
and my own experiences as a screenwriter
So, Jyn, Cassian, and K-2SO sneak into the Imperial base on Scarif, and steal the Death Star plans
And then, Jyn goes to the top of the antenna to transmit them to the Rebel ship, just like it happens in the movie
But, then, a Tie Fighter shows up and blows the antenna, that forces Jyn, Cassian, and K2-S0, who hasn't been destroyed, to return to the ground level, run through the battle,
and escape from a ship with the stolen plans to hand them off to the Rebels in person
Now another way this could go, since it seemed like Jyn wasn't particularly afraid of that Tie Fighter
Is that maybe, that ship is being piloted by one of her crew
Like Bodhi, or K2-S0, and that's how they get the plans up to the Rebel ships, and that would make sense
Like, if the shield was still up, maybe they could have used the Tie Fighter to sneak out
Either way, we know there must have been more going on on the planet surface from these deleted beach shots
So my guess is , there was originally a longer escape sequence out of the base, and into the battlefield, perhaps leading to a beach showdown against Krennic
Who, we saw trudging through a bunch of floating, dead stormtroopers in the trailer
And regardless, I think characters like Bodhi, Baze, and Chirrut were always going to die in this battle
And then, I think that originally there was another final sequence that we didn't see
With Jyn, and maybe a few others flying up to the Rebel flag ship with the stolen plans in person so, like, Jyn hands them off to a random Rebel soldier
And he's like, "Why are you handing me a floppy disk?"
And Jyn's like, "It's the stolen Death Star plans!"
And he's like, "How do you know that?"
And she's like, "Because my dad named them after a nickname he gave me, shut up, just hand this off to your boss asshole"
And then *whoosh* *Darth Vader breathing* Darth Vader's red light saber blade illuminates the hallway
Then, as the terrified Rebel rushes the plans to Leia on the Tantive IV, Jyn stalls Vader, engaging him in a doomed fight, which ends in Jyn's violent self-sacrifice
Both Vader and Jyn watch, as the Tantive IV jumps into Hyper Space
Cue CGI Carrie Fisher saying "Hope", and credits
Now, again, this is all just my fan-fiction version of Rogue One's ending, minus some hot Mon Mothma Bail Organa action that I left out just for your sake
But, the reason I think Jyn dying at Vader's hands could be possible is, it would make the finale a lot more personal for Jyn
Like, in this version, Jyn would actually see her mission succeed, as opposed to just like, flipping a switch, and hoping someone upstairs was listening as the Death Star wipes her and Cassian out
Also, it would give Krennic more of a sendoff too
With like, this wild, muddy beach shootout as his death troopers get taken out one-by-one, instead of a kind of rushed standoff at gunpoint with Jyn
Now, don't get me wrong, I loved the irony of the Death Star Krennic built beingused to kill him, and I thought Jyn and Cassian on the beach was super sweet and kind of poetic
But, I can also see a reality where that was an alternative to a much bloodier and a much more violent earlier cut of the film
And if you think I'm exaggerating, there were rumors about concept art for Rogue One
That included Darth Vader dismembering Rebel bodies, chopping them in half, and using them as human shields
So, you can imagine execs watching that version, and saying, like, "uhhhh, hell no, we're not going to have Darth Vader go Game of Thrones on this movie's hero. We've still gotta sell toys here."
And, as much as I would love to see that, who knows, there might have some other, awful, or just weird version of the ending that we're all very lucky not to have seen
And, ultimately, I was very pleased with the final cut of Rogue One
I don't care how the sausage gets made, I just need it
For $18 on opening night
Ok, thanks for watching, and check out the other Rogue One videos I did on the CGI for Leia and Tarkin, as well as an explanation of how the movie's timeline tied into A New Hope
Please hit Like and Subscribe to NewRockstars. You can also contribute to NewRockstars on Patreon, so a huge thanks to all of our donors, and if you aren't currently a Patreon, we would love your support
Alright thanks for watching bye